et gazoline étaient les pionnières il
faisait partie de l'ambiance dans les
concerts on allait dans le concert était
là
là où ça se passe et d'arrivée partout
et il désacralise et où ils m'amuser
parce qu'il m'entraînait dans leur
délire c'était tellement scandaleux de
sortir en travesti de dire j'ai le droit
d'être ce que je suis
tanné 68 à une révolution masculine a
été quand même du côté des hommes
révolutionnaire et donc c'est plutôt en
opposition à mai 68 mais pas d'une
manière réactionnaire plus tout pour
essayer d'alimenter une révolution qui
irait beaucoup plus loin que celle qui
est contre le capitalisme et donc les
féministes sont ajoutés le patriarcat et
les folles ont ajouté l'hétérosexualité
ça a touché les homosexuels mais on leur
a pas donné
l'occasion et l'opportunité de de
pouvoir se justifiant par les quoi il ya
eu évidemment un mouvement qui était
beaucoup plus légitime au vu de tout le
monde c'était le mouvement féministe les
femmes remettait en cause la notion de
patriarcat l'époque c'était le
vocabulaire mais surtout la prédominance
masculine la domination masculine
les homosexuels sont venus en dix ans
mais nous aussi nous mettons en cause
une certaine forme de masculinité ce
qu'il fallait faire c'était aller dans
le courant féministe qui était la brèche
pour une société plus libre les
homosexuels devaient peut-être montrer
une image de folles il y aura des revues
intellectuelles mais aussi des gens qui
vont dire on en a marre et on veut être
ce qu'on est ce qu'on essaie ça et donc
on a vu apparaître des travestis de là
va naître une scission tout de suite
entre les gens qui ont envie de c'est
pas comment dire vous passez par les
grossièrement [__] la merde
faire éclater
ces normes qu'on nous avait imposé de
l'autre côté les gens qui tout de suite
veulent devenir
considérés comme les autres ce qu'on va
appeler un peu plus tard les gay parce
qu'à l'époque c'était les homosexuels et
même lorsqu'il avait eu c'est de la
sorbonne en grève le premier manifeste
c'était marqué le manifeste des [__]
race était pas le manifeste des
homosexuels paix des races étaient
employées ou
péjorativement 1 [__] mais mais les [__]
entre très souvent s'appelait des [__]
il est pdg pas pdc 1 [__] oui c'est très
marrant et maintenant on dit gay ou
ce qui nous intéressait c'était là la
fois l'attitude voilà on aimer la
personne parce qu'elle n'était pas comme
les autres parce qu elle ne l était pas
gardienne d'une certaine masculinité et
parce que surtout elle se moquait
beaucoup des hétéros où elle se moquait
de la façon dont les hommes ne supporte
pas d'être pris pour des [__] ou des
choses comme ça ces individualités vont
quand même pouvoir s'exprimer
bizarrement dans les manifestations du
1er mai alors les homosexuels qui vont
devenir les gays vont rejoindre les
syndicats vont essayer de faire du
lobbying parmi les institutions tandis
que les folles vont toujours dire
laissez nous la paix les les [__] qui
veulent être normaux ça nous intéresse
pas les homosexuels
en 72
sa montée en eux parce qu'en 68 qui a eu
il ya eu 7 cette révolution mais qui
était pas ouvriers des homosexuels
n'avaient rien à voir là dedans donc ils
ont commencé à se réveiller à dire mais
nous aussi il faut qu'on ouvre ne te la
fait
puisqu'il était si mal traités donc ils
sont retrouvés of aux beaux-arts aux
réunions du phare et la sa fusée dans
tous les coins tout le monde vous mais
tout le monde faisait sont ces même pas
question de faire son coming out
c'était être fier c'était se révolter
mais non seulement avec des discours
mais avec avec avec leur personne donc
ils ont commencé à se maquiller à sortir
dans les rues maquillée et peu à peu
progressivement on s'habille en femme et
ça a toujours existé sauf que dans les
années 50 et 60 ça se faisait mais en
privé ou le jour de carnaval
parce que vous sortie en famille en
dehors des jours de carnaval et la
police nous arrêter et vous mettez une
amende après 68 y avait des mouvements
de libération de tout des femmes des
homosexuels entremont ya eu là donc la
création de ceux du front du phare c'est
à dire le front homosexuel d'action
révolutionnaire avec guy hocquenghem
gens comme ça et à l'intérieur donc je
me saoule manque était au départ
peut-être un peu théoricien peu sérieux
il ya eu bon bah automatiquement dans la
culture gay ya toujours pas mal de
fantaisie de glamour
et gazoline je crois voulait justement
remuer un peu le côté mystérieux des
militants gauchistes et faire un peu de
l'animation un peu de provocation pour
les dérider un peu elle est arrivée en
travelo est-ce que c'était sexuelle je
n'en sais rien en tout cas c'était pour
dire n'acceptons pas le costume cravate
nous n'acceptons pas le système travail
capital
nous n'acceptons pas cette dualité que
foucault théorisera ensuite
de ce lien
difficile à dissoudre entre eux
entre le domino elle domine et pégase
audi ont fait exploser tout ça et comme
elle n'avait pas un rond parce qu'elle
était
fauché parce que elle avait 20 ans 19
ans elle est étudiante et tout ça la
solution c'était de deivid dévaliser les
puces de montreuil et de trouver des
petites chemises est de 50 et elle
lançait du coup pour le coup elle
lançait des styles moi j'ai connu le
front me sexuelle d'action
révolutionnaire d'aix-en-provence déchu
est arrivé en 72 c'est à dire quand les
gazoline ont fait leur éclat à paris
mais je j'ai connu leur nom et leur
manifestation beaucoup plus tard ou
paris ou par l'intermédiaire d'une
presse gay qui commençaient à circuler
sous le manteau ou parmi les militants
comme le fléau social par exemple de
alain fleg et
des revues comme la revue recherches qui
avaient fait un numéro spécial qui
s'appelle 3 milliards de pervers on
était le fer de lance jeudi quand même
on par solidarité avec les gazoline
parce qu'on avait quand même la même
sensibilité on était le fer de lance
d'une nouvelle visibilité
voilà alors évidemment
c'était un peu spectaculaire puis il
reste beaucoup d'image malgré tout
puisque en fait comme encore aujourd'hui
dans les gay pride on retrouve surtout
comme image à la télévision les folles
et les travestis parce que c'est du
spectacle et que ça fait plaisir aux
gens malgré tout je suis venu à
aix-en-provence
d'une manière qu'on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui hétérosexuels message est
accompagné d'une fille dont j'étais
amoureuse je pense que c'était
réciproque mais ensuite j'étais un peu
débordé par mes désirs et comme c'était
un peu contradictoire j'ai fini par
abandonner cette compagnie
elle m'avait un peu encouragé d'ailleurs
allé avec mon premier roman je crois
mais on est elle n'était pas à l'aise
avec moi de cette façon là et beaucoup
de personnes se disait j'aime bien les
garçons mais je suis avec une fille
comment faire et pas de modèle on ne
vous aviez le modèle de l'amour
hétérosexuel la femme inspire l amour et
ensuite le désir homosexuel qui était un
désir de liberté puisque gratuit sans
amour seulement le plaisir ensuite tout
ça ça va s'organiser commercialement
mais à l'époque c'était pas vraiment ça
donc je rejoins le front homosexuel
d'action révolutionnaire s'était marque
à l entrée de la résidence universitaire
je pense j'ai encore en photo seul 221
je crois c'est ça j'ai eu un nîmois
sexuelle rien qu'à voir le mot fhar
front homosexuel mais c'était aussi
visuel parce que lille il avait repris
ces jours là que je ne connaissais pas à
l'époque une image qui était un phallus
et les qu'on trouve au 18e certainement
dans les cavernes mais j'aime bien cette
image et donc on allait danser
dans ces réunions pour parler évidemment
de révolution et rencontrer aussi des
gens qui ce qu'on retrouvait dans notre
lit ensuite d'une manière très
volontaire je peux dire que moi j'ai eu
j'ai été éduqué par des folles et
j'avais 23 ans 24 ans donc c'est pour
dire que ça peut ça peut se transmettre
pas comme un virus et que ça peut
s'enseigner
lorsque j'étais à alger pendant la
guerre là j'étais adolescente mais
j'étais déjà
marie france en diable et donc je fus
getty le dimanche après midi où les fins
de journées de chez mes parents et je
retrouvais de de trois personnages
exubérants alger c'étaient des gars au
café 5 6 ans de plus que moi ou
septembre il avait déjà 22 ans il était
instituteur mais était hystérique
s'habille en femme le dimanche
est y avait tous ces beaux parachutistes
qui débarquait pendant la guerre et qui
affolée et c'est toute cette jeunesse et
elle avait pris
l'habitude de crier bits
alors imaginé entre les bombes et les
grenades ses folles maquille crier bis
de la voiture en passant à toute allure
les ont été affolés voilà ça faisait
rire c'était terre espèce de soupapes de
deux parce qu'il y avait tellement
d'angoise tellement de de la guerre
nombreux mois en crayon beat aux
morilles et on riait et moi je ris en
tout cas ça me faisait vraiment rien et
donc quand j'ai rencontré les gazoline
je les ai trouvés un peu
similaire à ses folles que j'avais
rencontré à alger pendant la guerre est
gérée du bit
et elles ont adoré et après 7 heures le
cri de guerre alors elle rentre et que
ce soit dans les vernissages ou des
réunions ou au flore ou n'importe où
toujours elle veut elle surgissait et à
le crier bill it comme ça évidemment vu
tout le monde était affolée devoir
cesser gcil ses nerfs le même grief
blick comme ça donc c'est un petit peu
ma faute et c'est en ça que j'ai
participé à leur folie
[Musique]
cette horde sauvage
lesparre
avait le don de repérer avec beaucoup de
clairvoyance
ce qu'il y avait à faire
puisqu'il y avait un pas à ne pas faire
je n'étais pas là pour le voir mais ce
qu'ils avaient à faire
j'étais là et donc les quelques fêtes
innombrables que j'ai pu avoir chez moi
quand ça atteignait au dessus d'un
certain niveau sur l'échelle de chaîne
c'est quoi
arriver les gazelles et la consécration
de la fête a ici est en général une
tentative de sabotage de ladite fête
parce qu'ils avaient
différentes manille partout il arrivait
sur les beats
et vous aviez une bande 15 à 20
fille un peu étrange passé attention
c'était pas des simples transsexuels
raffiné sur gay pride maintenant qu'ils
se la joue on est des femmes etc non non
il avait dépassé ce stade depuis très
longtemps et il avait adopté la tenue
grenouille de bénitier
c'est à dire jupe en bas très long comme
ça tailleur années 40 étriqué et chapeau
à voilette avec un oiseau
sur le chapeau et c'est donc pas sexy
quoi oui est là il y avait sept bornes
de ne pas sexy qui avait 18 ou 20 ans je
sais pas quoi qui déboulait comme ça
hurle orbite on ne pouvait rien faire
contre les gazoline les gazoline
c'était ça débarqué comme un vent de
folie il consommer à outrance des litres
des terres ce qui fait que je
recommandais sur mes copains ne surtout
pas allumer une cigarette
quand il venait de passer mais il y
avait un risque d'explosion en dvi
nuages des terres qui traînait derrière
eux il carburait à l'extérieur comme
sera fait par la quelle mesure ils de
sniffer vraiment c'était vraiment pour
faire chier tout le monde et vous l'êtes
rigolote elle voulait en même temps
politisé activistes révolutionnaire et
drôle ce qui avait pas chez les autres
parce qu'il y avait tout le temps des
des manifs c'était tout le temps ou pour
au premier degré ou alors des grandes
réunions où tout le monde parle et des
discours qui n'en finissait plus et
voilà et c'est justement ce qu'elles ont
voulu changer elles ont voulu
amener à mener du rire un peu dans tout
ça donc il tapait un peu comme un
poignard dans de vie quoi mais c'était
toujours marrant parce que l'alors
interventions avec la famille ce que tu
voyais que qui avait traversé dans tous
les sens le savez tous
et
c'était fini mais enfin ça avait été un
peu la ponctuation de la soirée tout
était tiède camp avant que les gazoline
arrive un mois là même les cocktails or
évidemment moi je serais content eu
beaucoup plus les les gazoline
pour les soirées première les
vernissages et tout ça que pour les
manifestations
voilà je le faisais aussi mais
un hills à noël et dans les vernissages
les vernissages des années 70 déjà que
c'est rageant et chiant maintenant dans
les années 70 c'était la pompe eux d'un
chiant les mecs se la jouer c'est nous
les artistes
attention
l'oeuvre d'art
il s'amenait à enlever un message le mec
je sais pas s'ils se suicider après ou
pas ils détruisaient tout
ça mais ceux qui prenaient c'étaient les
petits sandwichs et les machettes à
basseau les tableaux temps on va ranger
ou à 30 service vous prenez ce métal et
sa salle a battu poussera fameux crédits
guerre il pourrait pas tout les gens
étaient terrorisés les propos qui
étaient là et tout est le vernissage
était complètement déglingué et basculer
parfois dans un autre sens qu'il sert
cette monnaie carrément barons ont
commencé à déconner c'est quand on
regarde leur attitude on se dit ouah
quel quelles libertés quelle audace et
moi surtout je rajouterais quel panache
c'est à dire que on est à mon avis dans
un dandysme absolue vraiment on est dans
un choc les gens mais on choque annexe
ti
pour moi les années 70 c'est les
montagnes russes
c'est une décennie
où on est comme dans un shaker
et si aussi des creux de vague et des
moments de pure
folie hystérie
ces décès une décennie dangereuse c'est
une décennie à double tranchant c'est
une décennie où on sort pas forcément
en plein de formes ou vivant 72 c'est
une époque de creux de vague terrible
parce que il ya eu 68 qui a été une
folie il ya eu 69 qui a été une haleine
en plus être une âme érotique a été une
année où on était dans les expériences
de toutes sortes soixante dix la musique
est insensé les popstars moeurs enfin ça
bougeait énormément et 71 à genk creux
tous les jeunes partaient en communauté
et et les boîtes s'attristait se vidait
y avait pas de grand bois qui avait pas
grand mais avec des clubs à l'époque
faut pas les grandes boîtes sont arrivés
plus tard donc les les ligues dit comme
ça les les les bandes d'amis énorme
jeunes et tout ça c'est arrivé en 72
avec les gazons
l'ambiance est retombée
je pense que dans certaines boîtes de
nuit
hippie chic pape et ça se confirme et va
y avait une sorte de désillusions
envoyée c'était la fin de liste de
choses et à ce moment là disons que les
gays ont pris le relais on peut le dire
parce que je vais arriver un moment où
les seuls endroits qui restait à paris
oui c'était la fête c'était un drogué
j'ai aidé aussi allait déclencher ces
garros et gazoline parce que c'est
gazoline à la base étaient tous étaient
des étudiants c'était des jeunes ils
avaient 20 ans moi j'avais quand même
déjà 6 7 ans de plus que ça ne se voyait
pas révélant d'une enfant bien sûr fumer
ça les fascine et ça les fascine et est
donc j'étais un peu leur mascotte
d'ailleurs hélène hazera était la
première personne que j'ai rencontrée
dans ce creux de vague dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure que je venais de
vivre où rien ne se passe et où
physiquement j'étais très très pâle
parce que j'avais abuser des choses dans
les années 70 71 que j'avais essayé de
me soigner et que sais je m'en sortais à
peine
et j'avais des amours tumultueuses aussi
et ténébreuse et beaucoup souffert ces
années 70 71 et 72 est apparu
est apparue une personne
charmante un
très jeune
je prenais un café avec une journaliste
très connu s'appelait katia côte qui
écrivait pour le nouvel obs est arrivé
se permettent ce personnage et je suis
tombé sous le charme et puis cette
personne elle m'a fait une cour énorme
en même temps faut il dire parce que
pour que je tombe sous le charme fou
qu'on me chambrent d'abord et est donc
ça a été le début d'une amitié
des personnes évidemment c'est hélène et
hélène avoue dû
m'aider parce que ces îles à elle voyait
bien que j'allais je n'allais pas très
bien et d'eau et j'habitais dans un
squad avec dédé avec des hippies
c'était vraiment un souvenir assez
glauque et l'aisne me dit aimer attends
je vais te présenter
marc raynal
et qui a un appartement à la moitié de
jeunes veulent bien je suis sûr qu'il va
tu vas te donner une chambre dans son
appartement tu sera beaucoup mieux tout
ça dossier c'est un peu une fratrie que
rencontrait un à mon avis c'était pas si
nombreux que ça l'a vraiment là l'équipe
elle-même ça devait être une douzaine de
personnes pas plus je les ai trouvés
bons fofolle mais intéressante parce que
dans toute cette borne y avait quand
même il y avait des idées des gens
brillants il y avait il y avait des gens
qui avaient des talents littéraires il y
avait il y avait michel créé sol plus
tard il y avait mon mot de molyneux
hocquenghem des copies tous ces gens là
c'était des gens d'une intelligence
exceptionnelle et encore une fois parmi
les plus bruyants bouillante dentelle il
y avait l aile hazera qui est un être
une grande niche cerner taxe entièrement
précieux intelligent et lucie et il y
avait aussi quelques filles ce qui est
assez étonnant n'y avait pas kita
paquita qui est également quelques
vraiment une grande énergie vivante
molyneux par exemple n'avait rien d'un
militant pour la cause de
l'homosexualité
alors ça je pense que c'était pas du
tout son affaire même si voilà le phare
même si les gazoline même si des actions
comme ça
on prouve pourrait faire penser le
contraire maud molyneux par exemple et
on nous a souvent dit que quand on
disait à maud molyneux
mode est une homosexuelle
nom
et huguet surtout pas surtout pas il
détestait ce mot qui est qui justement
go mais un peu les gommer un peu les
différences surtout pas es tu es
super d2 non mais non mais non donc vous
voyez ce que je veux dire quelqu'un
comme maud molyneux et même on peut
l'étendre jusqu'à marie-france bien sûr
quelqu'un comme maud molyneux c'était
quelqu'un qui s'habille a uniquement aux
puces avec des vêtements choisis dans
les années 30 des vêtements dont il
pouvait vous citez le mot la moindre
matière la matière du bouton la matière
du col enfin voilà et qui sortait comme
ça dans la rue on pouvait dire c'est un
outrage de sortir comme ça dans la rue
mais lui pouvez vous dire aux six mois
ses vêtements je les connais par coeur
je les ai choisis parce que c'est toute
ma vie un garçon de culture
extraordinaire extrêmement raffiné
capable
d'avoir une langue de vipère quand ça
lui plaisait comme d'être charmant quand
ils en avaient envie aussi on a commencé
à photocopier tout ce qui pouvait être
signés maud molyneux ou louer l'intérim
puisque c'était selon son deuxième
meubles ce dôme haut de molyneux pour la
mode cloud et l'intérim pour le cinéma
ça a été un choc quand même le style le
style très très littéraire très précis
très très pur ces grandes phrases délié
qui n'ont rien de journalistique mais
qui ont tous deux de littéraire qui sont
vraiment la littérature et surtout la
fin le style mêlée à l'érudition le
style plus l'érudition il y avait à
cette époque quand même toute l'équipe à
michel christol et allié au 15e qui
était de 2-2 célèbre philosophe
intellectuelle qui avait pleins pouvoirs
sur libé et libé était quand même le
journal de l'époque et tout le monde ne
pouvait pas ne pas lire chaque jour et
donc quand guy hocquenghem ou créole
parler c'est une page entière et il
était évidemment très très proche de
tout là toute la clique là c'est michel
créé seul qui a fait rentrer à
libération c'est arrivé prenant racine
surtout dans le phare dans le mouvement
du phare on parle d'un journalisme qui
n'existe plus on parle du journaliste de
libération des années 70 80 un
journaliste un journalisme ou quelqu'un
comme maud molyneux peut écrire une
phrase qui débute en haut d'une colonne
est fini en eau de la deuxième colonne
vous voyez un journalisme qui n'est pas
basé sur uniquement sur l'information
qui est basée sur l'information et le
style c'est le plus grand écrivain de la
mode après proust et mallarmé ou comme à
l'armée écrivait sur la mode parce que
ces fouilles et parce que c'est ultra
respectueux et parce que ça veut dire
quelque chose sur le vêtement mais pas
quelque chose de sociologique c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on a connu par la suite
quand dira ah le jeans est l'apanage les
non pas du tout pas du tout quand on a
envie de parler de maud molyneux on a
envie de faire de rattacher ça au
dandysme au 19e siècle on a envie de
rattacher ça à hollywood parce que la
grande époque d'hollywood années 40
parce que maud molyneux était fasciné
très influencé par ses pairs mais il ne
faut pas oublier que maud molyneux par
exemple en tant que critique de cinéma a
écrit sur l'actualité du cinéma quand le
film de science-fiction blade runner
sort elle écrit sur blade runner et elle
dit le tout le bien qu'elle pense de
blade runner quand manuel de oliveira
fait un film elle écrit sur la dernière
sortie de manuel de oliveira et elle dit
c'est un set un cinéaste capitale
quand le jeune cinéma cinéma philippin
et said émerger c'est maud molyneux qui
fait un grand article c'est au cinéma
philippin et qui dit c'est un cinéma
important donc ce n'est pas du tout
quelqu'un de nostalgique ou de bloquer
dans le passé quand on ne savait pas on
appelait mode mais comme les gens notre
nom tapez sur google savait qu tape sur
internet pour rechercher un
renseignement ça n'existait pas à
l'époque il appelait maud molyneux en
dix ans dans didon est-ce que tu connais
ce poète chinois fait et voilà donc ces
c'était vraiment quelqu'un d'assez
éblouissant pour ça michelle façade l'a
senti très vite c'était quelqu'un qui a
mûri une sorte d'oeuvre pendant toute sa
vie sur ses fascinations
d'enfance le vêtement le cinéma
hollywoodien puis qui a su régénérer ça
en regardant le cinéma actuel la
littérature actuelle qui était capable
d'aller lire l'anthologie de la poésie
chinoise parce que elle pensait qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui avait quelque
chose avait fouillé de ce côté là tout
le monde a les souvenirs de moments très
drôles avec aide
beaucoup de panache aussi lorsqu'elle
elle était capable de comme ça de
fulgurances et ce qui va avec l'humour
un grand sens de la vacherie elle
trouvait toujours la petite vacherie
adresser à quelqu'un ce qui était quand
même dans une rédaction comme il faut se
remettre dans la rédaction de libération
des années 70 80 quand même de fortes
personnalités ça c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et donc il fallait quand
même savent manier l'art est partie pour
se faire une place et il paraît que tel
et tel le maître incontesté de la
répartie là plusieurs versions sur le
départ de mode de libération bon il ya
déjà un fait qu'il faut reconnaître mode
écrivains de moins en moins à libération
donc faisait lé moindre moins d'articles
on est dans les années 80 le journalisme
prend une autre tous deux un peu une
autre tournure et donc un électron libre
comme maud molyneux s'est difficilement
gérable de plus en plus difficilement
gérable et là vous avez deux versions
dans les souvenirs des gens soit on l'a
poussé dehors en lui disant petit à
petit bon allez allez allez alors soit à
un moment il ya une histoire qui dit que
tu es serge daney qui dirigeait le
cinéma
libération qui allait lui parler qui lui
a dit ça peut plus durer il faut que
vous partiez et mode aura aurait répondu
tous est conditionnel aurait pondu
j'attendais que vous me demandiez si
elle avait décidé de dire tiens je vais
jouer
je vous dis n'importe quoi la vieille
dame acariâtre et puis on l'aurait
identifiés comme tels et on en aurait
fait une petite rubrique on en aurait
fait un personnage ça peut-être qu'elle
aurait trouvé une place dans une
rédaction dans une crue briques télé je
ne sais quoi elle n'a jamais voulu faire
ça ça l'aurait peut-être sauvé
d'inventer d'inventer un mode molyneux
de pacotille com sur lequel on aurait pu
mettre
homosexuel ou originales ou voilà non
non non mais elle n'allait pas jouer ce
jeu là certains disent elles d'autres il
c'est absolument impossible à trancher a
accordé vous d'accord vous ne faites pas
cela vous n'accordez pas levée enfin
vous êtes toujours pris entre les deux
l'époque c'est surtout par époque et ça
vous permet surtout de souvent de dater
des gens c'est assez amusant comme
approche un peu historique vous savez
que quand quelqu'un dit la mode on est
plutôt à l'époque la libération voilà
c'est qu'ils étaient vraiment son surnom
les ancien journaliste à libération 10
la mode voilà et après vous savez que
quand quelqu'un en parle au masculin on
est peut-être sur un proche qui l'a
connue avant des temps plus jeunes voilà
donc c'est à ces intrants châble
d'ailleurs c'est une d'écran une des
questions les plus fascinantes quand on
parle de mode molines chercher quelqu'un
d'aussi hors normes dans la presse
actuelle ce serait ce n'est pas possible
et alors j'ajouterai dossier hors norme
et d'aussi sincère parce que c'était pas
l'originalité pour être original c'est
il s'agissait pas de s'habiller en femme
pour choquer qui que ce soit pas du tout
c'était une vraie sincérité au coeur de
la personnalité de maud molyneux il ya
une ambiguïté profonde et qu'elle n'a
jamais voulu nier je pense que le grand
courage mais ça je crois qu'on pourrait
dire de beaucoup de personnes qui
étaient dans les gazoline ce sont des
gens qui n'ont pas voulu nier vous
réglez cette ambiguïté ce problème là
ils ont jamais voulu dire à un moment
voilà je suis quelqu'un comme maudit ne
l'a jamais dit oui je suis gay et je
revendique non il savait qu'il était
comme ça il n'a jamais réglé ce problème
là mais il l'a toujours assumé
publiquement les gazoline c'est un
groupe qui a rassemblé des
individualités très fortes en moi je
connais plus l'histoire de maud molyneux
hélène hazera bien sûr est quelqu'un de
complètement
je crois qu a pas d'autre mot que
fascinant que marie france qui est un
personnage un personnage incroyable une
artiste une artiste qui a peu
d'équivalent dans l'artistique français
mais j'ai compris à mon adolescence que
qu'en fait mon rêve c'était deux d'être
dans la lumière d'être cinéma et de
chanter la première qui m'a fait rêver
mais là je parle de mon adolescence de
mon enfance et bardos
bardot à vous apporter de la lumière
dans ma vie quand j'étais à oran enfants
et
ensuite la première star qui m'a inspiré
c'était quand même marlène
marlene dietrich bien que j'ai rencontré
dans les années 60 de deux garçons
américains qui eux trouvé que ge était
le sosie de jean mallot
alors il m'avait fait platine maquillé
comme elle et il me disait mais si tu te
bats l'aide comme ça à new york les gens
tomberont à la renverse ce que j'étais
vraiment chénard jenard l'eau mais après
j'ai découvert
marlène dans l'air dans dans ses films
des années 30 et et là c'était une vraie
révélation elle m'inspire énormément
dans son look je me suis habillée comme
ça pendant très longtemps avec des robes
des années 30 et j'avais vraiment le
style de marlène des sociétés dessinée
au milieu du franc les cheveux crantés
je jouais beaucoup là dessus et j'ai
fait mes débuts au cabaret d'ailleurs
avec ses inspirateurs justement marlène
en tête il y en a une autre qui s'est
pointé très peu après
et un peu
en forçant la porte si je puis dire il
ya un metteur en scène de cabaret qui
voulait monter une revue avec moi mais
qui m'a demandé de d'incarner mari dean
ce à quoi je refusais parce que j'étais
marlène dans l'âme et marilyn je vois là
je sentais pas trop parce que je la
trouvais tellement pulpeuse moi j'étais
blanche les vides c'est vrai que je
menais une vie à l'époque qui
qui
qui met des avoirs se teint très pâle
je mangeais presque pas et ça mais ça
c'est un autre lieu une autre histoire
c'était un petit peu là la condition
d'accepter un contrat c'était de ferme
d'incarner mari dean donc et puis alors
ils étaient très encourageants mais tu
vas voir tu vas divine je vais être très
maritime ça enfin bref gg fait mari dean
ça a plu énormément tout de suite et moi
je me suis intéressé à elle
immédiatement parce que ça collait terme
entre elle et moi et puis même les gens
autour de moi les gens étaient fascinés
[__] la presse on m'avait présenté
langlois donc langlois était un peu sous
le charme et il était très très gentil
avec moi il m'avait dit mais m'a dit si
tu veux si tu veux voir des films de
marilyn je te donne la petite salle en
haut de la cinémathèque si tu veux voilà
parce que tout d'un coup je voulais voir
tous les films de marilyn lire toutes
les biographies de marigny et c'est
alors elle a compté énormément pour moi
et j'ai fait ma ruine et aussitôt on m'a
proposé des choses très intéressantes
voilà des cabaret
prestigieux et des numéros avec des boyz
des vraies mises en scène et tout ça
donc je le faisais et avec amour cette
cet hommage à marilyn je me suis prise
au jeu et j'étais marilyn à la ville et
à la scène pour le coup parce que je
jouais était hors de question que je
mette une perruque je voulais être
platine et g je voulais m'amuser je
voulais rentrer dans la peau de ce
personnage et qui me touchait
terriblement et voilà ça a été une
réussite - et fonce à mon avis était moi
gazoline que marie france elle était
allée elle même elle a toujours été à
naître lille une exquise joliesse à tous
les niveaux dans son comportement
à la clé gazoline n'hésitez pas à se
vautrer dans une grossièreté très
calculée je pense que marine ont
ensemble éviter trop de se salir le bout
des doigts je fréquentais
les gens
de droite si je puis dire puisque
l'alcazar et tout ça s'était tenu par
des gens de droite ne faut pas oublier
qu'on est en 72 ha et donc et en même
temps tous mes nouveaux copains meetic
mes amants mes petits copains sont tous
de gauche mais activistes parce qu'à
l'époque
on
est on est très impliqué on est
politisée donc j'étais toujours prises
entre deux feux entre mes copains qui
était révolutionnaire de gauche et qui
avait qui menait une vie très très rude
comme ça où il fallait courir whif où on
avait une espèce de boulimie de voir des
choses de
et puis en même temps entre le confort
des gens de droite qui vous faisait
travailler et qui vous inviter dans des
endroits d'un des palaces et le
champagne et tout ça est donc j'étais
toujours entre ces deux mondes c'était
pas évident à gérer parce que parce que
par exemple d'homme dans les spectacles
travaillais
je souhaitais que mes amis viennent me
voir ils voulaient venir me voir parce
qu'ils étaient fans mes amis étaient des
fans à la base aussi c'est vrai il était
un admirateur ils me supportent tijd et
surtout très bande de gazoline et
d'intello de l'époque et est donc moins
jet ski et ski ma tristesse et que je
faisais ce spectacle et que mes amis de
gauche pouvait pas en profiter donc
donc s'il y avait toujours des conflits
ce que je voulais qu'ils rentrent et non
seulement j'ai d'ekeren mais je voulais
qu'on les invite
mais à l'époque il y avait la guerre
entre les gens de droite qui buvaient de
l'alcool et les genres de gauche qui
fumer des pétards et qui avait des
cheveux longs donc c'était c'était deux
mondes qui s'affrontent est comme ça
alors jean marie vien a très souvent
mais qu'est ce que tu m'emmerdes avec
ces gauchistes là et tout ça donc il les
recevait pas moi je piquer des crises je
m'engagerai avec lui on se fâchait voilà
ya ces magnifiques en un temps très dur
dans l'histoire de gazoline puis ensuite
dans celle de maud molyneux que je
connais un peu mieux je pense qu'on est
à chaque fois obligé de dire oui mais
c'est à dire qu'on est obligé de dire
post soixante huitard
sans doute mais parce que on n'arrivera
jamais à 10 à aller mettre dans une case
ne serait-ce lorsque toutes les guerres
de ligne sont très différentes ne serait
ce que parce que il faut compilé plein
d'éléments de contexte post 68 la place
de l'homosexualité en france à cette
époque
une fascination dans le cas de maud
molyneux est sans doute de plein
d'autres pour le dandysme 19e
les années 70 la vie nocturne les boîtes
de nuit qui commence vraiment à devenir
quelque chose à paris et vous compilez
tout ça alors sans doute que mai 68 a
son rôle à jouer là-dedans mais
je crois pas que ce soit la seule à lui
mettre de la mèche à la chose négative
de ces années là
c'est que
il y avait beaucoup de drogue très dur
vous parle avant les gazoline parce que
des gazoline will et gazoline à la
limite prenez un verre de champagne avec
un amant drague ce pourrait être un peu
plus délirantes mode raquette un
somnifère donc somnifères alcool
d'imaginer ce que ça peut donner plus
leurs délires naturel
voilà mais avant ça il y avait ce qui a
déferlé sur paris c'est quand même les
groupes très très dur mais on prenait sa
commune fatah l'époque c'était pas du
tout désespéré de notre part de toucher
à ça c'était une fête mais il ya eu des
pièges après forcément donc voilà trop
de fêtes
addition très lourde on commence à
rentrer dans une époque où le rêve et
hippies se casse la figure les grandes
espérances nées de 68 et en ça je pense
que les gazoline ne sont pas des enfants
de 68 parce qu'elles ont un côté
désenchanté aussi sur certains espèrent
peut-être pas les gazoline mais le
mouvement par la suite en tout cas les
individus par la suite c'est qu'à la fin
des années 70 le monde devient plus dure
la crise se profile le monde devient
plus on
l'a droguée plus dur elle se drogue
festive est finie et on rentre dans
quelque chose de plus dur et est donc on
a une quand même la leçon qu'on peut
retirer de ces gens là c'est qu'ils ont
on peut la retirer pour nous on est en
pleine période de crise qu'on fait cette
génération café cette génération 76 83
ils ont fait la fête comme jamais ils
ont fait la fête comme jamais ils ont
été créatifs comme jamais comme comme on
peut des papes
quelque part et c'était c'est ce moment
là qui est très intéressant à l'époque
commençait à devenir vraiment
oppressante et ils ont ils en ont tiré
cette cette énergie créative bon ce qui
ne pouvait pas savoir ses murs du sida
api qui attendaient derrière ça
effectivement ça a été un
drame
[Musique]
finalement les années 70 et 80 et est
asser assez comme ça bouche et sur pas
mal de sujets c'était pas la grande
liberté mais sur plein d'autres choses
étaient assez assez tôt les tolérances
finalement donc à la fois vous aviez
envie de faire voler les volets les murs
et puis et puis dire et on chante on
change tout et en même temps c'était
possible de le dire il y a eu si vous
voulez un basculement enfin cette
période qui était la période 67 10 75
par là où il y avait donc encore les
freaks et tout d'un coup est intervenu
un événement
qui m'a beaucoup marqué
qui a été le l'arrivée en groupe à paris
de provinciaux très branché est très
intelligente est lucide qui se foutait
éperdument d'être payés ou pas [__] et
qui venaient pour la plupart de nantes d
assez curieux et
c'est devenu ma groupe moi j'habite est
d'ailleurs dans les halles philippe
morillon habiter un peu plus loin de
chez moi enfin bref on s'est retrouvés
tous ensemble et on est devenu ce qu'on
appelait la bande des halles et la bande
des halles n'était plus du tout les
fluxs e radical cassure total
intervention de lou reed son premier
concert appareils et révélations tout
d'un coup c'est à dire que jean bleu
marine foncé baskets blanches tee shirt
à manches noir cheveux courts blonds
décolorés net car est limpide urbain et
tout d'un coup la lucidité urbaine vient
remplacer ce mouvement fluxus qui était
lui-même le remplacement du mouvement
hippie un donc contre on situe un peu
les choses hélas cette île qui assure
enfin bon il ya eu tout un micmac donc
le passage était difficile mais s'est
fait quand même en douceur parce que le
la communion et qu'à la limite ça
m'avait beaucoup mieux d'être avec ces
mecs là qu'avec des feuilles qui se
complaît j'étais moi même ayant tu vois
et et demi
jean [__] et demie commerçants à
succès
il m'allait bien et donc je me suis
lancée dans la mode à cette époque là
j'ai créé une ligne de vêtements pour
rester près d'eux et on s'est retrouvé
avec toute une équipe comme ça qu'est
dans laquelle est restée pâtit ta moan
et quelques personnalités de gazoline
qui ont en quelque sorte un aussi
franchi cette cette vague un peu des
sorties ovales et les sortirait sur une
autre énergie qui était plus vivifiante
peut-être plus et plus pêchus plus drôle
[Musique]
à la fois la crise la créativité et
aussi ce qu'était paris alors moi
l'ayant pas connu ce que tu t en
province à cette époque là la ville que
pouvait être paris à l'époque qui ne vit
qui n'était pas étouffé par les par
l'immobilier étouffé par le marché
immobilier où les gens pouvaient vivre
dans paris et des gens comme maud
molyneux
comme comme toute cette bande comme la
bande du palace les je ne pouvais vivre
dans paris sortir dans paris c'est je
pense que là on vit un moment new york
un peu vécu ce moment là la même période
à peu près en vie un moment assez
exceptionnel d'une capitale d'une
capitale qui à mon avis c'est pas très
exagéré de comparer ça à un moment
comparable aux années folles c'est un
groupe parisien oui ce que je veux dire
je crois que les gazoline n'ont pas fait
beaucoup de bruit à montpellier ou à
bordeaux ou marseille c'était un vote
très parisien très branché au sens de
l'est de l'époque dans un milieu à un
peu un peu d'avant garde comme ça les
gazoline ensuite les bandes qui traînait
au palace qui si vous voulez nous enfin
on aurait beaucoup de difficultés à être
dans paris actuellement économiquement
socialement et cette époque c'était
possible et c'était des gens qui de
toute façon était viscéralement parisien
ce qui s'est passé de terrible à mon
goût c'est qu'au bout de quelques années
il va tomber deux trucs sur la gueule
qui sont impitoyables le premier qu'il
est quel monde c'est là
c'est à dire que tout d'un coup on est
passé du du pétard à la shooteuse
elles furent hélas moi je me souviens
combien de fois j'étais en train de
conduire ma bagnole et je regarde
l'homme aux rétroviseurs et tout d'un
coup je vois derrière briller
discrètement les clac quelques aiguilles
dans les bras des fautes qui sachant que
je n'aimais pas ça mon proposait plus et
se shooter en cachette mois à la
chanteuse donc redoutable mais ça n'a
pas été le pire ce qu'il aurait tant
aimé le pire soudain coup ceux qui se
sont fait tomber dessus par les têtes
chercheuses
des grandes fortunes on leur a proposé
de devenir
les porte étendards de la branchitude
friqués et donc la mondanité doré tomber
sur la gueule
avec entre autres le palace et des
endroits comme ça et tout d'un coup tous
ces gens là qui dansent et des pavés en
68 se sont mis à bouffer des petits fous
et les coupes de champagne on est passé
à côté d'une autre ville qui aurait pu
se réaliser parce que cette équipe là la
bande et al on n'était pas 12 là on
était 200
et pas des mois là étaient des gens
tellement intelligent tellement brillant
tellement malin tellement tous il
pouvait faire des choses étaient urbain
il était conscient
ils sont calmes et la sape arranger les
choses mettez un autre mouvement une
autre idée et le gazole il était mon
avis du passé
c'est devenu comme une sorte de fleur
qui s'ouvre
est peut-être c'est ça qui les a aussi
tout d'un coup un peu désemparé c'est
qu'ils avaient peut-être moins le
deux choses à combattre jeu c'est
parfait ils sont un petit peu éparpillé
et
personnellement je suis resté en contact
surtout être paquita puisque paquita à a
eu une action très importante appareils
dans le milieu de la nuit en et en
particulier que de moi direct et du
palace pendant des années à partir de 76
pendant 77 il faisait partie du passé et
ils ont été remplacés justement
peut-être par des garçons comme didier
lestrade et des mecs comme ça qui ont
pris les choses vraiment politiquement
main et qui ont dit nous on veut être
totalement libéré de tout préjugé contre
notre liberté
de faire ce qu'on veut de notre vie de
notre sexe le nobu on emmène tout le
monde ne faut pas qu'on nous fasse chez
eux ils ont arrêté de rigoler quoi comme
il en a arrêté la veille de l'été a
emmené les machins et c'étaient des gars
sont organisés ils ont fait le front de
libération ils ont fait la gay pride ils
ont petit à petit arriver à faire élire
mitterrand et donc pas toi mans
mitterrand était élu
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses pour
libérer la société de
ses préjugés et de ses se règle
[Applaudissements]
et une situation qui est évidente entre
en trouvant des gazoline et la marche
d'aujourd'hui même si ce n'est pas
toujours très très évident pour tout le
monde le sens premier démarche que ce
soit à paris ou en région et d'ailleurs
c'est encore plus plus plus important en
région c'est cette notion de visibilité
alors à travers cette visibilité on
interroge aussi
la norme interrogée la norme le poids
des normes la norme hétérosexuelle
hétérosexiste on pourrait bien de notre
société c'est aussi l'objet de ces
marches certains peuvent trouver
exubérante
mais justement c'est d'interroger cette
norme un peu par la provocation aussi
pour certains
mais voilà c'est de donner finalement
cet espace de liberté de prendre la rue
on considère que cette journée la rue et
aux lgbt
donc la visibilité interroger la norme
et puis évidemment revendiquer sa part
être essentiel on passe de la
revendication sur la visibilité sur le
droit d'exister
tel que l'on est à une revendication
peut-être plus institutionnel mais plus
sur les droits le fait d'avoir les mêmes
droits que les autres alors certains
pourraient dire que du coup le mouvement
lgbt aujourd'hui cherchent plutôt à
rentrer dans cette norme puisque on
réclame puisqu'on demande le mariage on
demande la reconnaissance de toutes les
familles etc etc et donc finalement ça
reste aussi des institutions qui étaient
dénoncés au départ par par les
glissements
homosexuels et pour autant ça traduit
aussi une évolution des mentalités la
société parce que plus accepter les lgbt
aussi demandent aujourd'hui à ne pas
avoir traitement différencié vis-à-vis
des autres et d'avoir tout simplement
les mêmes droits et quand justement on
met en avant cette question du du
mariage du droit au mariage pour les
couples de même sexe
certes on veut avoir le droit de se
marier mais aussi le droit de ne pas se
marier est posée pareil cette question
du mariage
à des hétéros il ya plein de terreau qui
veulent pas se marier c'est pas pour
autant qu'on va interdire le mariage aux
hétérosexuels donc voilà il ya toute une
série de revendications et de discours
qui font qu'on demande aujourd'hui tout
simplement à avoir cette liberté de
choix liberté de choix qu'on n'a pas
liberté de choix sur sur comment est ce
qu'on souhaite organiser notre vie le
message qu'on a aussi à faire passer
c'est un message de non jugement certes
on n'a pas à juger
quel est le bon le mauvais comportement
en société ou pas d'ailleurs donc c'est
aussi ce message là qui avait véhiculé
par un marché le fait qu'on mette un
focus 1 peut-être sur
comment dire sur une forme d'exubérance
plus important de tel ou tel moi j'ai
pas juger ça et au contraire je pense
qu'il faut le montrer justement parce
que comment dire c'est chacun doit
pouvoir être libre de vivre sa vie comme
il l'entend
de la vivre au grand jour et on n'a pas
à nous expliquer à expliquer à qui que
ce soit que il faut rentrer dans une
case qu'il faut se comporter comme ça
qu'ils auraient une homosexualité normal
et nous nos sexualités plus je sais pas
exubérante déviantes et c'est tout ce
que vous voulez et non justement tout le
monde a sa place dans cette société tout
le monde devrait avoir sa place dans
cette société c'est ce que notre marche
revendiquent je pense que les gazoline
sont un mouvement culturel elles sont
des perles de patrimoine l allemand
toujours été présenté comme des
personnes qui avaient un savoir
extraordinaire dans le domaine dans
lequel les excellent et je pense
sincèrement qu'il sublime est leur
engagement et qu'ensuite effectivement
cette attitude a fait converger des
individus des individus
exceptionnel on voit leur parcours
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça je pense que
quelquefois il ya une hésitation à
parler de leur histoire dans le
mouvement homosexuel parce qu'elles sont
maintenant respecter reconnu à partir de
cette revendication ils ont su en faire
elles ont su en faire part de ce groupe
a su en faire un
un moment quasiment esthétique de
dandysme c'est aussi tout un mouvement
de fierté d'être ce qu'on est d'affirmer
pas forcément une identité mais la
liberté d'être ce qu'on est
[Musique]